495 le nombre de publicités recensés sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est pour mieux les encadrer
qui est élaboré ce rlp y règlement local
de publicité intercommunale les élus du
conseil communautaire en ont validé les
principales orientations une phase
supplémentaires après la concertation
publique et les discussions au sein des
12 conseils municipaux des communes de
l'agglomération
le règlement local de publicité en plus
touche au cadre de vie touche aussi à
notre quotidien
et puis également à l'activité
économique et donc faut qu'on arrive à
trouver un texte qui fasse consensus qui
soit équilibrée pas d'excès de tous les
côtés et que jose d'équilibré qui fasse
qu'on puisse maintenir notre objectif de
lutter contre la pollution visuelle et
lumineuse mais aussi de respecter le
cadre légal
on est d'accord tout en préservant le
dynamisme économique de notre territoire
au total six orientations définies pour
ce règlement de la publicité parmi les
principales interdire les publicités
murales scellés au sol ou sur bâche dans
les zones d'habitat les autorisés dans
les zones commerciales et d'activités
réduire le nombre de panneaux et en
limiter leur format enfin l'extinction d
affichage lumineux notamment les
publicités numériques entre 22 heures et
6 heures du matin 67 élus ont voté pour
cette délibération deux se sont abstenus
à coignières on craint notamment la
multiplication des publicités le long de
la nationale 10 on nous propose
effectivement rl pays qui était en
principe je dirais restrictif qui devait
réduire en partie la publicité mais ô
paradoxe à coignières le rl pays
finalement va accroître la publicité
dans nos zones d'activités
donc il ya là effectivement un problème
de son côté le collectif résistance à
l'agression publicitaire dénoncent un
projet peu protecteur le rl pays doit
être arrêtée définitivement avant l'été
une grande enquête publique sera ensuite
lancée avant un vote du règlement d'ici
la fin de l'année